dropped at midnight yep got it at 1201
the fans are describing it as energetic
and life-changing they can't get enough
there's a new teaser with fierce fashion
stilettos fringe and a cowboy hat never
before seen rare family pics cuddling in
bed with her three kids and a letter
thanking fans for waiting despite the
leak quote i appreciate you for calling
out anyone that was trying to sneak into
the club early yep beyonce gave the
beehive plenty to buzz about just a
whole lot of people
lizzo halle berry megan the stallion and
of course mom tina lit up social media
all hailing queen b's record-breaking
first solo album since 2016's lemonade
i'm a fan too and i'm very very excited
i really miss her singing and she put
two years of love into this
oh and she wasn't afraid to put family
drama into renaissance either seemingly
addressing jay-z's cheating in plastic
off the sofa
so i'll let you be and that 2014 met
gala elevator fight with solange is
seemingly referenced in the song cozy
[Music]
mrs carter collabed with jay-z and of
course big frida on her 16-track record
which she calls the first of three acts
i was honored to be a part of something
so
iconic and so amazing
um it's still breaking my soul
[Music]